this is what you get when you have an
almost unlimited budget
england will start their world cup here
at the khalifa stadium against the
iranians on the first day of the
tournament the usa game will be inside a
huge arabic tent albate stadium holds
sixty thousand and then in here for
either wales scotland or ukraine
in total 1.2 million people are expected
to descend on doha but organizers have
blockbooked almost every hotel room and
haven't yet released them
well if you go on booking.com or airbnb
now you're talking like 50 60 grand for
a month for an apartment or in a room
but the actual hotels and stuff you
can't really bought you know there's
literally no availability but there's
plenty of beds available but they're
just not available to book yet um so i
can understand that there will be some
people out there that can all know what
we're gonna do i'm pretty confident that
everyone will get a bed somewhere
so too are the hosts
what we have actually promised that they
will be um
experience catered for every fan so
whatever anyone would like to come and
to enjoy in this country they would find
it
many places are still being built and
giant cruise ships will line up in the
bay
but if you can't afford any of that
there is this
you need a 4x4 to get to it
or a camel
but the small resort on this beach will
put up hundreds of arabic tents
it's a massive expanse of sand and this
is where one of the fan camps is going
to be yes so they are planning to put
some uh camps here five-star service
amenities and facilities for sure
do you think there could be problems
with lots of people from different parts
of the world mixing and drinking and
enjoying themselves for us we will be
flexible and we will prepare for that
for that event
scottish and welsh fans will have to
wait until june before they know for
sure if they'll need somewhere to stay
it's a little bit of a
disadvantage uh that we're not there and
that we you know we might have to make
you know wait another couple of months
but
you know provided we get there i'm not
particularly fussed you know we'll take
our tents we'll take our sleeping bags
we'll sleep on the streets um
i'm 39 now i've waited 30 years to watch
wales in the world cup
some visiting teams and fans will choose
to make a point of highlighting the lack
of gay rights here qatar's promise that
everyone is welcome will be tested but
they intend to exceed expectations tom
parmenter sky news doha